[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever
we want we got some g in the house
thanks for having me all right
yeah speaking of moving out i wanted to
ask you
are you local to l.a yeah i'm in culver
city i mean were you like
raised here no i moved to los angeles or
just outside los angeles in 93.
oh from where uh i lived in florida for
six years before that and then before
that
i lived in saudi arabia for three and a
half years and then i spent my first six
months
in jordan where i was born oh you follow
all that you cannot be president of the
united states
i cannot be president and i swear to god
as a kid that bug and it really made me
sad it would bug me
yeah i know that i can be president
imagine coming to a place even i could
be president dude
i know it's just feeling you guys will
never but i mean just like as a kid
i automatically wrote off politics as a
young kid because they said
you can't be president you know they're
telling little kids you'll never be pre
imagine being a kid being told
you'll be a governor look at it so you
could be a citizen
but you can't be a president unless
you're naturally
naturalized citizen or right you have to
be born uh
how bummed is arnold because arnold
literally conquered every [ __ ] thing
he ever ever tried he would have
president he would have won president
arnold he would have won absolutely and
then it's going to have to be the rock
probably
oh that's awesome i look forward to i'd
vote for him
i think undertaker should run frankly
the undertaker would get that right-wing
radical right no
problem jesse ventura's a [ __ ] i love
jesse ventura unironically and
ironically
yeah but he's he's hella russian now
what are you talking about oh he went
like the steven seagal route yeah
he's out there i think he's making
content on russia today
and then like yeah you know he was like
a was it a senator or governor of
governor yeah the great state of
minnesota
he got into some conspiracy stuff a
little bit yeah
stuff that i believe firmly interesting
guy yeah i mean
i like it i like somebody who's got
wacky ideas but with like a strong
regular core value system poor value
they get out here sometimes that what he
talks like it's actually very very good
and i'm very proud of him his
impressions are underrated was he also a
navy seal too yeah
yeah wow he did a lot yeah he did a lot
and he was in predator with arnold
both of them became governors he also
got sued
by the american sniper family
really yeah because they said that he
punched um
the guy out the main guy from kyle chris
kyle they said that he
they said that chris kyle punched him
out
at a marine corps party because he was
disrespecting the marines and not
something i would never
do and and so he almost sounds like sean
connery
oh yeah my shoulder is like this oh yeah
it's close no
do you hear the difference that's huge
at such range no but that's what
so he um sued them successfully sued the
kyles
um for defamation because that was
[ __ ] yeah
and you put some in a big movie like
that people are going to believe it wait
jesse ventura punched them
no if jesse interior they chris kyle
says that he punched jesse ventura out
for [ __ ] talking the marines at a party
and there was no witnesses who could
corroborate the story
and so chris college was trying to make
himself look like a badass basically oh
and then he's like no one punched me
right yeah and then he also jesse
ventura went like
how do we know all this [ __ ] that he
claims is true is true which is super
[ __ ] interesting
because once you put a movie out like
that everyone just believes it right
and you put bradley cooper in the role
oh yeah i believe it's just one of the
most believable guys on screen
super believe it so are you do you still
have your jordanian
citizenship yeah sure do yeah and what
are some benefits i'll never go back
no i went back in 2014
to visit family and like kind of just to
meet family for the first time since i
was born there and it was uh
it was very interesting there was a lot
of
when i moved to the states i was like a
kid with an accent didn't fit in with
americans right and then when i went
back in 2014 i was like this middle
eastern kid but who
like speaks you know perfect uh english
and doesn't have an accent coming back i
didn't identify with any anyone imagine
having like your family
you know some of them who you only see
this much of but like you've never
spoken to and you can't speak to because
of the language
there's a lot of like head nodding a lot
of like my mom and dad having to uh
translate and stuff like that you spoke
was it farsi or arabic arabic
yeah you spoke it before as a kid and
then you forgot
i spoke a lot of it and but my parents
my dad spoke english to me so i was like
i did both
oh like at a 60 70 level
and then it went just english 100 and
yeah do they talk to each other in
english your parents both they do both
yeah yeah oh you still didn't weren't
able to i can understand
some of it like when they're cursing me
out or like
you know when they're angry i cannot
hear a big curse uh
i understand you know you know yeah
yeah there's i'd like to get cussed out
like that it sounds good yeah it's kind
of romantic i feel like since it's an
ancient language it's
all metaphors like made the goats horns
fall off it's always animal stuff like
if you call somebody in and like if you
call somebody uh in arabic a cowboy it's
a dog like you call somebody a dog whoa
dude like it's like saying
[ __ ] i called my uncle a dog one time
you know in arabic and like
he slapped the [ __ ] out oh no yeah yeah
what was it so i
saw it over it the one that you just
said what does that mean uh son of a
horror or something like you know that
sounds worse than dog yeah well
you know at least [ __ ] stand up to eat
you know
you know dogs say squat [ __ ] don't
always have to be walked
so yeah uh look great place great place
to visit on a short
and if you're unmarried don't go like
you're not allowed really
you would yeah you
it would be weird wow yeah you would
want to just go to the main city
and stay out of the suburbs very very
traditional but like
among the arab states more more uh
progressive than like
saudi arabia where i also spent time you
know as a kid
but we lived in a compound so it was a
walled off area
where all the um expatriated people
lived and then people that are
uh just all from all over the world come
and live in these compounds because it's
safe
and there's like a you know it's like a
gated community a little bit more
progressive in these compounds
yes and the outside of it you know you
could you know it's
it's bum [ __ ] it's like you know the
equivalent of like alabama no offense if
you're from alabama
but your whole state is bum [ __ ] i want
to go to alabama
lovely i'm sure i want to see a guy with
three teeth and overalls with a little
straw yeah straw just coming out with a
banjo that's the mayor you just
described the mirror i drove through
alabama
really how was it did you see the old
way is it in between
texas and louisiana that's how people
feel when they're going through alabama
louisiana is
on texas i think is it [ __ ] i forgot
yeah
texas louisiana
mississippi alabama because i know the
hurricanes
go in breck houston too when i do run
for president i don't think i'm going to
win alabama by the way no i don't think
any of us will
you know what on this video there'll be
a comment from somebody that's like i'm
from alabama and i couldn't agree more
like there's always the oh yeah
or but then there's the guy who's like
i'm from alabama and i i'm writing this
from the internet i'll have you know
which we have no i got it mixed up with
arkansas because we did go
to arkansas oh this is something i don't
do enough of
pull up a map of the united states yeah
was that right
yeah louisiana is touching louisiana
mississippi alabama okay
and i lived in florida right after saudi
arabia which is
uh a lateral move what part of florida
kissimmee
which is if you know florida is the
chicest part
right where walt disney world is we
weren't consuming it's a tourist trap
it's not kissing me it's not cassidy oh
i thought that was kissing me
i thought i tried to change it uh it's
weird you know alligators are just
crossing
the highway it's just weird which part
of florida is that
it's right it's near orlando it's oh
it's really worth
vidcon wait no what the [ __ ] is it
called playlist playlist florida
playlist
that's where we went where we stayed in
playlist was where my father worked at
the uh
career royale no there was it was the
one before that like the
the world trade uh convention center one
marriott career brielle was the that was
yeah that was the beginnings my friend
it was the log ride of hotels yeah yeah
yeah and then you guys came down to
california and then in 93
made the jump to california had to break
up with a girl at the time i was in um
fourth grade she was in fifth whoa yeah
well she was in the bright she was a
bright student she was in the gifted
class
and i had to tell her i'm moving to um
california this summer so where'd you
break it we're gonna become a surfer
we're at universal studios that's [ __ ]
up
we're on a like a a class trip to
universal studios and it's kind of
romantic because we spent that day like
we'd never see each other
again and on my podcast on my podcast i
re i remembered her name and i reached
out and then people were sending me the
address
her address creepy yeah so i'm
investigating they doctor but there's a
few there's a couple of them but they're
like
uh this could be her this is the right
age she had lived in where you lived at
the same time and like
so like thank you you know to those guys
who i'm i'm sure are gonna be
in prison soon huh did you ever hit her
up no not yet do you have a picture of
her i need to see a photo first are you
going to send her like
a letter like what will i do send her
like a like from universal like the last
memories you had
holy [ __ ] that's so scary that's so
creepy you know what you can probably
don't write don't handwrite anything
like cut out all the letters
just so like because what if she can't
read your writing right almost like uh
like a ransom note
you can probably ask alexa because
today's video is brought to you by alexa
and i love alexa because uh when me and
chew are having fun in the kitchen
not in that way um no one thought sure
sounded like it
one of the favorite things to do is i
don't even know what the name of this
game is
but we'll see we made it up but hey
alexa play this and we'll
we'll have a theme like whether it's
colors so we try to out
um brainstorm each other with songs that
have colors in it or songs that have
numbers in it
or songs about certain cities and
they'll just play
whatever song that we request and it's
super fun and i'm always looking for
ways to make my life easier we're all
juggling too much
so the ability to upload so the ability
to offload even the smallest tasks can
make a difference
one convenience that i can't believe i
live without smart bulbs connected to
alexa
and right now amazon alexa is offering a
special smart lighting bundle for my
listeners
and with the amazon smart lighting
bundle you can turn your home into a
smart home in just a minute setup is
easy
and you don't need any extra equipment
just connect your smart bulb
to the echo dot and you're all set set
every possible mood we should probably
get this so we can set the mood with our
music
with over 16 million light colors to
choose from or control the lights in
your home
with the sound of your voice just say
alexa turn on the lights
you can also set lighting routines to
gently wake you up in the morning help
you wind down at night or
completely turn off at a certain time
right now you can get 20
off of your amazon smart lighting bundle
only at amazon.com off the record
every bundle includes an echo dot smart
speaker
and a singlet color changing light bulb
that's 20
off at amazon.com off the record
so sometimes i come home and nikki's
talking to the amazon alexa
and she's having it tell her a story how
cute that's sad i think you need friends
man like
like what what kind of story like like
it'll tell you all kinds of stories like
three little bears
if you say alexa tell me a story she
will full-on tell you a story like would
she tell me the drama between like
offset and cardi b
i don't think she don't think that that
might be kind of cool i fired alexa the
other day i was like alex you're fired
and it was like
well i will be working for myself she
was very professional
i like her i um reached out to an old
flame
i was like uh about maybe 12 went to a
camp
meeting kind of thing and then um she
became a girlfriend
but we had to break up because the camp
was over
and i totally lost her and we we we
would uh
write letters to each other call on the
phone and then um she was like yeah i
don't think
uh my dad thinks he doesn't believe that
we're gonna stick together
and i was like what he doesn't think
that and then i got so heartbroken that
her dad thought that that i stopped
talking to her
oh my god improved his point but i was
like 11
right i was so stupid maybe i was
younger than that like nine
i don't know but anyways some time pass
and then facebook you could stalk people
pretty good right
so i typed in their name real good i
remember the cd she was in
and i was looking at it and i was like
hell no i'm not gonna message her she
turned out not too good
what if she did that [ __ ] to you too and
she's like i'm about to hit joe
[ __ ] because you guys never technically
broke up
we're still together dude i had that
happen to me
so i was living in virginia we moved to
california san diego
and i was you know my girlfriend at the
time that's like when you're in fifth
grade
they're your girlfriend but you never
really talk to them say yep
or hang out it's a title yeah it's just
like hey i like you you like me cool
we're boyfriend girlfriend now
so i remember moving all the way to san
diego and for like a year anytime a
chick would try to like
talk to me or anything like that i was
like you know i just literally you know
i have a girlfriend but i
had no means of communication with her
what's that it was so funny we had no
internet or like any of that kind of
[ __ ] like way of messaging each other
nothing at all whatsoever i didn't have
her address nothing
i just i'm such a die-hard ass loyal
[ __ ] when did you stop being loyal then
uh when one of my friends was like dude
we haven't you talked to her [ __ ]
year what are you stupid like what are
you doing
and then that's when i was like oh yeah
okay it's time to move on it's good
quality
cute you've been a monogamous guy since
i've known i mean i don't know what
you're really doing
you know but uh i've i've never seen you
rifle through the babe since i've known
you you've stuck
you've had he's always been a
relationship guy like he's in like
long-term relationships yeah i'm
generally the same way
i've only had i've only had a short
spurt you know maybe a couple years
where i was
babe rifler babe rifler yeah that was
good i mean i wasn't
but even then it wasn't a lot it was
just kind of like uh
it was the first time i think i've i had
sex and been like
you're not my girlfriend you know so
this is okay for us to just
go do our own thing and maybe never
speak to each other again that happened
to me once and i couldn't handle it
i couldn't [ __ ] you fell in love yeah
no no well i tried to fall in love
afterward but i was like oh i'm not into
this
why what happens i had a one-night stand
with the chick who came to one of my
improv shows i was pretty good that
night
and she was pretty into me and then we
went to dinner afterward with like the
whole
crew and i invited her and then we ended
up going back to her place
we [ __ ] and then which does i don't do
that kind of [ __ ] right
so i was like oh [ __ ] and the next day i
was
like trying to kind of force it like
maybe a romantic
flame there and battery you feel guilty
i talked to yeah i felt kind of guilty
maybe but i i
i tried talking to her texting her she
called me a couple times and
i just i ended up seeing her the second
time and then i was like okay i'm good
so you broke it off yeah but that was my
one night stand that i really just
dragged into something
just trying to make it my usual thing
because yeah you should do like two
a couple more nights down just to make
sure i did one more
half story i did that what i call a half
stand is it a bloated makes it a half
stand i kind of called it
like she actually emerged naked
from like the her room i love when that
happens yeah and i was not into it at
all whatsoever and i
was the same person yeah same person so
it was a half stance because what
happened you needed love
if i'm not emotionally into somebody i
can't [ __ ]
do it what happened the first time i
kind of agree with that we were drinking
yeah
alcohol alcohol now i i don't i don't
drink alcohol so it's like
there's no lubricant to you know there's
it's everything is just
bone dry sober when you're trying to get
in the mood and it's way
more difficult what does that say about
me because i don't need love to [ __ ]
and i'm sober all the time i think
that's on a t-shirt that should be on tv
that's clean living yeah you strike me
as a guy who doesn't have a lot of like
possessions
you know like you don't have to have
something i have um
i think he's more open with his darkness
and it's pretty pretty light
and whereas i think our darknesses are
perhaps a little more
uh in the in the dark like
we're like what like um
we both were acne kids who like uh oh
your sadness yeah because i thought
you had like dark secrets like yeah man
i let [ __ ]
nikki stick a candle up my [ __ ] and
light it up
and then the candle wax drips i would
talk about that on jk news actually if
that happened so the darkness is like
things you're ashamed of
no it's just it's just drama maybe that
you went through as a kid or whatever
or some stupid it's buried that you bury
with a
laughter or a hopeful laughter for many
many years
without therapy that's the darkness
i got darkness too guys maybe that's why
you're having those dreams
chopping up people that's years ago that
was six seven years ago i don't have
dreams anymore remember
you're living your dreams everyone's got
their [ __ ] but i admire your ability to
just
like you know be a hook be a hooker yeah
i do actually hey your samurai hair
really came in i need some form of
connection
it doesn't have to be love but some form
of intimacy he says thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you